bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france le premier ministre
israélien a annoncé ces restrictions
hier avant un conseil des ministres
naftali bennett qui veut éviter un
nouveau confinement le temps presse et
ce qu'il a déclaré quelle est la
situation dans le pays
et harry frère on a 1000 cas par jour
maintenant et la situation s'aggrave
elia de peur que 20 %
provient de deux lots mettront
donc israël
et maintenant on voit des retours amer à
certains instruction qui était déjà dans
le passé et il faut dire que les
istréens laissant déjà déjà habitués qui
cache ses pairs les vacances les
vacances privées compare tout je
voudrais dire qu'on a vu des images des
israéliens qui se posent aux et au bac 5
et il faut dire qu'il s'agit des très
très petit groupe en comparaison avec
l'europe et est donc bien sûr on peut
toujours montré que les personnes qui
disent des choses qui nous appellent les
sédiments en europe mais
manif des personnes ou des vingt
personnes et c est ce qui est très très
limité c'est vrai qu'au début et des
secteurs entiers de la population
comme elle et les hauts revenus rothen
mais ses stents opposées au vaccin mais
maintenant ce n'est plus le cas parce
qu'ils ont compris l'importance
de la vaccination et israël
monsieur pénètre la vie et en pleine
quatrième bague la cinquième vague et
auch rapidement et dont il ya
malheureusement ce retour est à ccc ccc
ce blocage est du pays des à des
touristes étrangères bazoum histrion
bien sûr et bien
voilà donc c'est malheureusement
c'est la situation et fois encore
insisté sur le fait et il serait elle
est très disciplinée
française qui pensait dans la
vaccination est maintenant il ya de plus
en plus et 10 femmes qui étaient
là et troisième injection
juste sur les restrictions concernant
les
l'étranger israël a placé plusieurs pays
sur une liste rouge la france l'espagne
notamment
comment est-ce qu'on accueille cette
restriction en israël selon
côté
incompréhension ça veut dire
s'agit de pays aux deux israéliens
avaient l'intention de partir
il ya des touristes qui arrivent mais
c'est vrai
au
cas des nouveaux cas en israël et ont
été et ont été trouvés chez les
touristes - 20
% et des cadets loïc tron était
était et trouver sèches et des touristes
venant des pays étrangers en fumée rien
derrière les états unis et la france aux
français on est troisième fillon
sur les manifestations vous dit que
c'est une minorité
la campagne de vaccination allait
débuter fin 2020 en israël le pays et
semble avoir toujours une longueur
d'avancé justement sur
la vaccination par exemple les enfants
de 5 à 11 ans peuvent désormais se faire
vacciner sur ce point précisément la
vaccination des enfants
loin de faire l'unanimité
ailleurs on le voit bien comment cette
mesure est accueillie encore par les
israéliens
écoutez bien sûr qu'il y a cette crainte
est de d box in et des enfants ella ella
qui l'accueille avec toujours une
compréhension nispel et parce qu'il y
avait de très grandes campagnes enfin
c'est qu'ils ont une mémoire longue se
souvient de la vaccination contre la
polio et les produits par exemple
c'était une maladie qui était d'abord
maladie des enfants et personnes et se
poser à l'époque non c'est quelque chose
qui touche tout le monde les enfants
sont malheureusement des vecteurs
de cette maladie
même s'ils sont pas en premier lieu du
danger de ce point de vue il ya les
réticences normal mais je pense qu'en
israël on accepte mais
les restrictions et de ce type
pour l'instant cela trouvez le
bon résultat
justement comment comment vous expliquer
ailleurs on accepte moins bien les
restrictions les mesures de restriction
mais aussi le passé ni terre qui va
devenir un pass vaccinale en france par
exemple alors quand l'israël vous dites
vous même la contestation elle est
minime selon votre analyse comment vous
l'expliquez
écouter d'abord les sre elle n'existe
que les passes vaccinale ce qu'ils
appellent passe vers l est pas et
vaccinales et
c'est très difficile d'expliquer ça pour
des repas pour des raisons
à la une analyse historique et pas du
tout un analyste politique et
en israël
on peut dire drac et
les ja le pays avait l'habitude
l'habitude du des très isolé depuis
depuis le début de leur existence donc
de ce point de vue les phénomènes qui
existent en europe et en europe n'existe
pas et on peut voir aujourd'hui un
européen ne peut pas voir partout que il
y a un lien très direct et est entré la
politique vaccinale
les copines en général et la politique
l'état des relations entre les
différents états et cela dit il est très
difficile et des ddd
que les différents pays européens
adoptent une politique différente et ce
qui est maintenant le cas ce qui est
maintenant le cas et donc l'unité herpin
de retrouver est en train d'éclater par
exemple la hollande et les pays-bas
rentrée politique c'est plus facile avec
la grande bretagne
et là on paie tout de suite est annoncée
voilà des restrictions sur la musique
des britanniques dont il faut jamais
oublier je pense ce lien est entré la
géopolitique et la politique et
sanitaire et la politique du corps id
ceci explique en fait peut-être les
problèmes la problématique et dans
différents pays à ce qui concerne cette
lutte nécessaire contre
contre les différents varia merci
beaucoup à vous gideon coutts je le
rappelle vous êtes journaliste israélien